Even the missing parts are perfect in her area, and the
manager Noe of the team that works with us came up with the idea of ​​​​creating a unit to make the novels easier, such as ``You're a liar, you're a genius.''  He
called me as the person who created the song, and we worked together to find a vocalist.In the process, we
uploaded various cover videos.I
thought it would be nice to see Lee singing, so I
decided to call her and decided to do
it.Bino
Compo  Ebi is a unit that makes music from novels
[Music] I
actually read that theory and
decided on the sound based on what kind of things I should use to express the worldview of the novel as sound.  Sometimes the melody comes to me while I'm deciding on the rhythm or
creating the sound, and sometimes the
music video is an animation after I start with the sound part.
[Music] I'm
thinking about it, and the lyrics are Japanese, and the
songs that I proudly thought were cool
ended up on the charts, where people not only in Japan but all over the world
can listen to them.
After becoming involved in this project, I felt once again a sense of
pride as a Japanese artist, and it
gave me confidence that we can aim for music like this to the world.  There
was a long time when the only way to connect with us was through the internet and listening to music via streaming, so we were able to listen to that live sound.  I've always wanted to deliver it to you as soon as possible, and as
musicians,
of course we want to make good music, but at the same time, it's
that strong feeling that we felt in our live performances, so we're able to get a
good feel for the current state of play.  I
think it's very important to have a live performance in order to receive a performance, and it
may be an isle,
but in the first place, I was asked to
perform an idol as the opening theme for the work, and I
think that's the thing about the original work.  It's a work that depicts the light and darkness of the entertainment world in a
very realistic manner, so there are
quite a few theories about those aspects, such as how people see you as a person who is out in the public eye, and
how you want to move on.  There
were so many things that I could relate to, such as the worries of whether or not to go through conflicts, and conversely, the joy.
[Music]
When we released a song and posted an immature video on YouTube  I've been seeing a huge increase in the number of comments and messages sent by fans on social media, and
comments from fans who live overseas, and it's
even on the Billboard charts.  But I think that we have a lot of overseas fans
listening to us, and
from their point of view, they don't have the chance to meet us on a night out in Japan, and they don't have
many opportunities to see us perform,
so I'm really glad that everyone is listening to us.  If the music that I
always listen to at home and in my everyday life could be
heard live and be very stimulating, I'm sure they
would like going out at night even more, and those Japanese
artists are really cool.  That's what I want people to
think, so in that
sense, I put a lot of energy into my work.
[Music]
Well, I also started
singing a lot of Ayase-san's songs during my activities with Anobi.
In addition to this, my singing
technique has also improved,
and I've
learned a lot more about my singing style and sounds than I thought I would be good at.  So
I thought, oh, I can sing like this, or if I
use my voice like this, it becomes such a cool song.This is also the case with
this idol song.  I
think it has had a big influence on me as I have started to take on challenges in my own activities because it brings out my voice.Even in my own songs, I try to sing the
songs myself and play songs that I offer to Vocaloid artists.  Most of the songs I
make are based on what I want to do at the moment,
so I
don't have anything that really sets me apart, but I still have a lot of
experiences that I probably wouldn't have had if I had done it alone.  After all, I was
able to learn a lot because I was on a night out,
and I was able to come to LA and be interviewed, and
of course, I was able to see it because the two of us came out on a
night out.
I think of it as a scenery, so it's also about my own life,
but I've started thinking about things I want to
accomplish even solo, and how I would do the things I've been doing on nights out by
myself.
Because of that, the shea has simply spread a lot, so that
also affects the solo
[music].This
is just as important as the song itself.Of course,
qualifications also affect the way the work
sounds.  I think that the music video will change, so the way the
song sounds
will change depending on what the music video is like. To be honest, it
might look really good, or if it's a rough one, it
might sound bad.  So,
when it comes to
choosing a creator and how to
make it, which is very important, we don't
have much of a meeting with the animator/creator of the music video beforehand, but it's a good fit.
Most of the time, a song is completed without even realizing it, but
rather than conveying the image that I think the person who created the first song had in mind, I try to convey to
each creator what you thought when you heard this song.  I think it's better to leave the creative ideas to the creative minds of others and
create a scientific response that gives us more opportunities to
experience the excitement of being able to bring out the charm of a different song.
Yes, that's true for our live shows in Japan, and we're also
planning a lot of live shows overseas, as well as
album releases, singles,
new songs, and plans for our next release.  There are
a lot of songs that I'm making now, so I hope you're looking forward to them.H